متاعبه مبكرا هل توقعها بنيامين نتنياهو
حكومته الاحتلافيه الجامعه بين التطرف
اليمني والتشدد الديني تواجه ما بدا انها
اولى الضربات
الاسرائيليه العليا تبطل تعيين زعيم حزب
الشعسه الدينيه
في الحكومه التي يشغل فيها حاليا
جنائيه
ان قرار لثاني ياهو بتعيين درع وزيرا كان
معيبا بشده وينطاوي على انعدام معقوليه
متطرف وان على نتانيا نقله من منصبه يتوقع
متابعون للمشهد في تل ابيب اي اهتز بذلك
اتلاف نتنياهو الحكوميه ويزداد منسوب
التوتر بينه والمحكمه العليا بسبب خطه
اصلاح قضائي مثيره للجدل
تلك التي خرج الاف اسرائيليين قبل ايام
لابداء معارضتهم لها هؤلاء يخشون ان
التوليفه الحاكمه الجديده تنقلب على
النظام القضائي وانها تسعى لانهاء اسرائيل
كدوله ديمقراطيه وفقا لما يقولون
والحقيقه ان الخشيه من توجهات ذلك لائتلاف
ليست اسرائيليه صرفه
على عناصر حكوميه الاسرائيليه بعينها
خيمه المساله بشكل جلي على زياره وفد من
اعضاء الكونجرس الامريكي يضم ما يعرف
بتجمع اتفاقات ابرهم في مجلس الشيوخ فبحسب
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه وامريكيه طلبت
رئيسه الوفد
عندما اشتراكه ممثلين عن حزبين دينيين
ممثلين في حكومه خلال الاجتماعاته في
اسرائيل
يتعلق الامر هنا بحزب العظمه اليهوديه
وحزب الصهيونيه الدينيه اللذين يراسهما كل
من وزير الامن القومي اثمار بنج فير ووزير
الماليه بيتسرائيل
كما يبدو على تقديم العلاقه مع اداره بيضا
في واشنطن ربما تثار المساله بطريقه او
باخرى خلال زياره المرتقبه لمستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي جاكسون لاسرائيل تلك
زياره توطئ التي ستقود وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه الى اسرائيل هو الاراضي
الفلسطينيه اواخر الشهر الجاري لكنها وفقا
لمسؤول امريكي
[موسيقى]